y describan esa experiencia.
(Risas)
Sé que es difícil, ¿no?
Pero, por supuesto, no espero que hagan eso.
Todos se sentirían incómodos y avergonzados
Y entonces imaginen a una chica de 11 años en Oriente Medio
que no fue educada sobre la sexualidad,
que fue sacada de su zona de confort,
su familia,
que fue testigo de la ejecución de su padre y hermanos,
teniendo que describir en detalle
la violación a la que se enfrentó en una cultura donde lo sexual es tabú.
Su única manera de recuperar su honor es esconder el crimen,
creer que fue casada contra su voluntad,
o negar los acontecimientos por vergüenza o miedo a ser rechazada.
Entrevisté a una chica a la que voy a llamar "Ayda".
Fue comprada por un líder de ISIS, o emir,
junto con otras 13 chicas de edades comprendidas entre los 11 y 18 años.
En el grupo estaban sus tres sobrinas y dos primas.
Las 14 chicas fueron llevadas a una casa llena de combatientes del ISIS.
Un imam estuvo presente, que dejó claro que su religión era errónea,
y el único camino bueno era aceptar el islam y casarse con un hombre musulmán.
El emir escribió los nombres de las chicas en 14 pedacitos de papel.
Dos combatientes del ISIS elegirían un pedazo de papel cada uno.
Gritarían el nombre escrito en el papel,
y esas chicas serían llevadas a la fuerza a otra habitación.
Mientras el emir y el imam escuchaban a las dos chicas gritar,
mientras eran violadas,
empezaron a reírse.
Ambos les decían a las otras chicas
que las dos chicas deberían disfrutar la experiencia en lugar de gritar.
Después de un rato, las chicas fueron llevadas de vuelta.
Estaban en shock y sangrando.
Confirmaron que habían sido casadas y sufrido mucho dolor.
Es importante considerar el hecho de que habían sido criadas
para creer en las relaciones sexuales con un hombre en sus vidas:
su marido.
La única conexión que pudieron hacer en su estado de choque
fue definir sus violaciones como matrimonio.
Antes de que las siguientes dos chicas fueran llevadas para ser violadas,
Ayda tomó una terrible decisión.
Como la mayor del grupo, convenció al emir
de dejarlas usar el baño para lavarse antes del matrimonio.
Una de las chicas dijo a Ayda
que notó veneno matarratas en el baño.
Las 14 chicas decidieron terminar con su sufrimiento
bebiendo el veneno.
Antes de que el veneno tuviera pleno efecto,
fueron descubiertas por el ISIS y llevadas al hospital,
donde sobrevivieron.
El ISIS decidió separar a las chicas
y venderlas individualmente.
Ayda fue llevada a otra casa y brutalmente violada
después de que intentara de nuevo suicidarse con su velo.
Fue golpeada y violada cada dos días.
Tras cuatro meses de cautividad,
Ayda encontró el valor para escapar.
Nunca volvio a ver a las otras 13 chicas.
Entrevisté a Ayda varias veces.
Estaba dispuesta a hablar conmigo porque escuchó de otras víctimas
que allí había una mujer de ONU que comprendía su complicada cultura.
La miré a los ojos
y escuché atentamente las historias de su hora más oscura.
Establecimos una conexión personal que continúa el día de hoy.
Mi educación me facilitó la comprensión de su extremo sentido de la vergüenza
y miedo a ser rechazada.
Este tipo de investigación no consiste solo
en recopilar información y evidencias,
sino también en apoyar a las víctimas.
Los lazos que establezco con las víctimas
fortalecen su confianza y su deseo de buscar justicia.
Mientras consideraba su escape,
Ayda, como todos los supervivientes yazidíes,
se enfrentó a un dilema:
¿debería continuar sufriendo el abuso de sus captores,
o sería mejor volver a casa,
donde se enfrentaría la vergüenza, el rechazo
y posible muerte por honor?
Conozco demasiado bien el dolor de ser rechazada
por mi comunidad marroquí en Bélgica,
y no quería que esto le ocurriera a la comunidad yazidí.
Un grupo de entidades interesadas,
incluyendo la ONU, varias ONG, políticos y miembros de la comunidad yazidí,
nos acercamos al líder religioso,
Baba Sheik.
Tras muchos encuentros,
se dio cuenta de que estas chicas no habían faltado al respeto a la religión
al ser forzadas a convertirse al islam
y casarse con combatientes del ISIS.
Que, en cambio, fueron secuestradas, violadas y esclavizadas sexualmente.
Me complace informar que, tras nuestras reuniones,
Baba Sheik anunció públicamente
que las supervivientes deberían ser tratadas como víctimas
y aceptadas por la comunidad.
Este mensaje se escuchó en toda la comunidad
y finalmente llegó hasta las supervivientes cautivas por ISIS.
Tras esa declaración de apoyo,
las supervivientes estuvieron motivadas de escapar del ISIS
como hizo Ayda,
y muchas jóvenes yazidíes dieron el valiente paso
y volvieron a casa a sus comunidades.
El pronunciamiento público de Baba Sheik
salvó las vidas de muchas jóvenes yazidíes
tanto en cautiverio como después de su escape.
No todos los líderes religiosos aceptaron hablar con nosotros.
Algunas víctimas tuvieron peores desenlaces que las yazidíes.
Por ejemplo, solo 43 de las 500 a 600 víctimas
de la comunidad chiita turcomana
fueron capaces de regresar a casa tras escapar del ISIS.
Algunas fueron aconsejadas por sus familias
para permanecer en ISIS
o cometer suicidio para salvar el honor de la familia.
Alemania estableció un proyecto para apoyar a las supervivientes del ISIS
proporcionando apoyo psicosocial y vivienda a 1100 mujeres y niños,
incluyendo a Ayda.
Visité a Ayda varias veces durante mi trabajo.
Estoy muy orgullosa de ella y de las otras víctimas.
El progreso que han hecho es sorprendente.
Es realmente conmovedor ver cuántas de ellas,
a pesar de sus dificultades,
se han beneficiado de este programa.
Este programa incluye asesoramiento individual y colectivo,
terapia artística, terapia musical,
actividades deportivas,
cursos de idiomas,
colegio y otros esfuerzos de integración.
Lo que observé es que alejar a las víctimas
de un área en conflicto a un país en paz
tenía un impacto positivo en todas ellas.
Este proyecto llamó la atención de otros países,
y estaban interesados en ayudar a más yazidíes.
Las mujeres y niñas yazidíes aún me llaman y escriben
para contarme sobre sus notas en el colegio,
viajes divertidos que han hecho
o para informarme sobre sus sueños futuros,
como escribir un libro sobre lo que han enfrentado con el ISIS.
A veces están tristes
y sienten la necesidad de volver a hablar sobre los eventos.
No soy psicóloga
y me he enfrentado a un TEPT secundario por sus terribles historias.
pero las sigo alentando a hablar,
y sigo escuchando,
porque no quiero que se sientan solas en su sufrimiento.
A través de estas anécdotas,
veo emerger una imagen más grande.
Estas mujeres y niñas están sanando.
Ya no tienen miedo de buscar justicia.
Sin esperanza no puede haber justicia,
y sin justicia no puede haber esperanza.
Todos los 3 y 15 de agosto, son mi día del recuerdo,
y me acerco a los yazidíes para dejarles saber que pienso en ellos.
Siempre están felices cuando hago eso.
Es un día emotivo para ellos.
El agosto pasado, hablé con Ayda.
Estaba muy feliz de anunciar
que una de sus sobrinas, que fue secuestrada con ella
había sido finalmente liberada de las manos del ISIS en Siria
y regresó a Irak.
¿Pueden creer eso?
¿Después de cuatro años?
Hoy, su mayor deseo para toda su familia,
ahora ubicada en tres continentes,
es reunirse.
Y espero que lo hagan.
Cuando pienso en las supervivientes con que trabajo,
recuerdo las palabras de una médica egipcia, escritora,
y activista de derechos humanos,
Nawal El Saadawi.
En su libro "Mujer en punto cero",
escribió: "La vida es muy dura
y las únicas personas que viven realmente
son aquellas más duras que la vida misma".
Estas víctimas han pasado por un dolor inimaginable.
Pero con un poco de ayuda,
muestran cuán resilientes son.
Cada una tiene su propia perspectiva del tipo de justicia que busca,
y creo firmemente
que un proceso de justicia creíble es clave
para cómo ella reclama su dignidad
y pone fin a su trauma.
La justicia no es solo sobre castigar al perpetrador.
Se trata de que las víctimas sientan que los crímenes cometidos
han sido registrados y reconocidos por el imperio de la ley.
Para mí, ha sido la experiencia de toda una vida
trabajar con estas supervivientes.
Porque comparto su pena,
su idioma y su cultura,
nos conectamos en el nivel humano más profundo.
Esto en sí mismo es un acto de curación:
ser escuchada, ser vista,
o tener compasión en lugar de condena.
Cuando nos acercamos tanto a personas con dolor
esto también crea dolor a los investigadores.
Mi trabajo es exigente, descorazonador e inductor de trauma.
Pero déjenme decirles por qué lo hago.
Cuando me encuentro con las supervivientes de estas atrocidades masivas,
cuando tomo sus manos y miro en sus ojos,
no borra mi propio dolor,
pero hace que casi merezca la pena.
Y no hay nada distinto que preferiría estar haciendo.
Cuando veo a estas valientes supervivientes
luchando para conectarse de nuevo con su propia valía,
con sus familias, con su lugar en una sociedad que las valora,
es un honor dar testimonio;
es un privilegio buscar justicia.
Y eso también es curativo
para todos nosotros.
Gracias
(Aplausos)